all right
frank yang
we are live thank you so much for coming
on the program
thanks for having me bro atlas infinite
bra
infinite bra yo guys check out
check out my uh zotero uniform
it's not snowing i'll start to wear that
but it's too hot right now
i have a stringer inside this is my
three layers of the onion my string
inside and this and the zoho chan
oh we're going to talk about the street
three stages to the absolute so
i am so pumped for this conversation
unbelievably pumped the
more to the
absolute we go inward the in a sense the
less
dialectic we can have
about it that is really resonant
and it's kind of like when you get to
the level of lebron james and michael
jordan
there's only a few basketball players
that they can play with
now and so that's what i've noticed
about where you've gotten
in your understanding of who we are and
why we're here
is that it's made it
so that i i can tell based on what
you're communicating
about your realization about the nature
of reality
that this is going to be an optimal
convo because we've
gotten to that one end and we're
communicating it in somewhat similar
ways so yeah that's yeah yeah yeah
i'm yeah go ahead yeah i heard you say
like on your uh youtube videos like the
analogy of video games and um
infinity expressing itself it's just a
very
very simple way to get to the truth like
you have like two-step things like okay
uh you're a separate self with the clown
and then you're a petting awareness
you're the sky okay their step you
disappear into the boat and then you
become former emptiness
so simple bro a little
stuff too i wouldn't know what you were
talking about when you say tantra just
like two months ago but i started to
look into like zolchan
and tundra stuff and it just makes sense
just after you realize emptiness you go
to the tetragraph where you fill them to
form but the problem is a lot of people
are doing tantra without realizing
emptiness first
so they get stuck in content without
realizing that the content of the
context are one and the same
you find the empties in the form from
the emptiness yep yeah
yeah and this is the heart sutras core
and emptiness is form form is emptiness
and
we'll let's actually go right into the
steps
yeah because i think it's i think it's
so important to go right in so
also what's so interesting about frank
is that
infinite bra over here is a really good
eloquent and punctual
communicator about what's going on and
so
you and i come from a practice that has
gotten us
here that actually has a lot of
similarities
so both of us have sat the theravada
buddhism vipassana meditation retreats
10 days zip shut the [ __ ] up
don't say a word yeah what
dude people can't even shut up for one
day i remember when i
first heard that people didn't talk for
10 days i was like
dude i'm gonna be in the pool of people
that there's only like
whatever a couple thousand or tens of
thousands on the planet that have ever
been able to shut the [ __ ] up for ten
straight days
and tap into what happens when you do
that
i was scared when i first heard about it
but i just knew i had to do that
about it before i went to my first
retreat
it's that's a component of it for us
then zokchen is another component of it
for us
and then uh i'm i'm i'm not sure which
spiritual mystic literatures you've read
but the doubt of ching confucius is
analects is another one
that i've really liked i've really liked
the old and new testament i've loved the
sufi metaphysics
so have you also kind of looked at some
of those
mystic tradition literatures as well
not as much not as much i come from like
an uh
background in fitness and art and
philosophy and
neurosciences i like to worry about
psychology and through that i started
transitioning to uh
spiritual practice because i realized
that oh i just wanted to explore
consciousness i just want to explore how
the mind works
because at first you feel the body and
we mix on the body what's left oh you
spill the brain
when you mix it on the brain quote
unquote make something right you can't
really make it on the brain but yeah i'm
just saying
um when you quote unquote max on the
brain you go into the mind then you go
to consciousness and realize that
consciousness is not what gives rise and
manifests
all the other stuff from before the body
the mind the brain the
entire reality at least from that of
direct experience
and uh so i i a lot of the stuff that i
read when i first started on the path
was pretty mainstream like ecuatoli and
yep uh
jen mckinnon um yeah
i tend to read the more modern stuff
it's like when i was into philosophy i
used to read a lot of
i never really read that much of the
original text
i always kind of read the like the more
modern interpretation of it
uh same with spirituality and then i
went to my first retreat and after that
i got into the more
uh some of the more on duality stuff
before my first version i didn't know
what non-duality was really i was just
into the more basic mindfulness stuff
and then i went to the grouper spiral
route you know yeah
all that those guys and then uh that's
when i started to uh
abiding that i am and then my third you
know my second retreat sorry my second
retreat after that i started to get into
the
pragmatic dahmer stuff which is the uh
the guys that i interviewed with
uh yesterday michael taft and uh daniel
ingram uh kenneth folk
trudeau she's in young all those guys so
everything almost everything i know
about the old school buddhism are
from those guys filter through this guy
but i know i've read i'm reading the
tibetan book of the
dead right now so yeah i'm getting a
little bit into like the original stuff
so yeah beautiful beautiful
i i also take a very as you mentioned a
very scientific as well as
neuroscientific and psychological
uh edge to this as well it's a synthesis
of science and spirituality
in many ways yeah go ahead yeah one
thing do you ever do pick up
oh like pick up artists or pick up
basketball
pick up pick pick up pick up girls pick
him up pick up artists yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah i think 9 out of 10 people
that i talked to who were on the path or
couldn't finish the path at one point
they either became they were either
bodybuilders
or they were pick-up artists yeah yeah
that's so
interesting so yeah because aesthetic
aesthetic is a big part of it yeah and
this
was the game of psychology with getting
in the shortest amount of time possible
getting somebody to say yes
you know where i got my path from
in that regard to sales i did so much
door-to-door
sales selling so many different products
and basically it's knock knock knock
hey i'm gonna educate you about
something that you may be interested in
and then within you know five or ten
minutes do you have their credit card
information are you closing the sale
you know how can you build trust that
quickly which is very similar with like
a pickup artist
is trying to like build rapport and
trust really quickly
to to get yeah and bodybuilding
aesthetic
yeah i think one of the reasons because
i think it's not just particular stuff
that we do it's because we come from all
those different angles
yeah it's almost like yeah so it's not
really about a couple of the cells it's
like oh bodybuilding and sales and
pickup this seems so opposite and
the other side of the extreme from
critical spirituality and that's why
that's exactly why a lot of people get
into spirituality you'll
go really deep into it but deep at the
other side of it because when two
extremes
go to the end they meet yeah they look
yeah it's all about the loop same thing
yep yep and actually the word
polymath is probably one of the best
words having learned much
across different fields because when you
do
that process what happens is you
basically
do what alan watts said was the many
paths in the one
end the many paths in the one end yeah
and so you see it from all of those
different paths and angles and signposts
and
all this type of stuff that are not just
spiritual but it's also scientific it's
also entrepreneurial it's also artistic
aesthetic it's emotional quotient it's
all of that stuff mixed together
okay so my bit here to play with would
be i
also did a lot of not only the old
school mystic stuff
but i got just a lot of the modern stuff
that you listed too
dekker tolley the audi ashanti the muji
the rupert spyra
even our even our friend bentino massaro
who is al is also young and
is realized and has also been
uh something someone interesting that's
helped me
along the path uh quite a bit and so
it's kind of interesting seeing a lot of
young people
that are maybe even in kind of like
their
their 20s or kind of in their 30s now
that are picking this up let's yeah
i love that guy man i talk i talk to him
like every day less nowadays because
he's busy doing his retreat right now
but
there was a time like after after my
awakening where he really kind of helped
me integrate by just being a friend
like for like i think for like five
months we used to talk every day just
like bros and stuff
yep yep yeah and that's the thing
because
again it's like the michael jordan
lebron james thing is that
like there's not going to be that many
people that you can really vibe
on the level of both simultaneously the
void as well as infinity expressing
itself
so okay so let's let's play with
our stepping stones here i'll go ahead
and recap a couple stepping stones and
then you'll hit the tennis ball
over with your thoughts about this so
okay so generally speaking
the idea of like sotapanya or stream
entry has been something really
interesting that i think we've both been
um fascinated with and i think
stream entry for me has had a lot to do
with
sometime at my first meditation retreat
learning about even the idea of
being an observer or a witness to the
clouds of
thoughts and emotions and feelings and
beliefs and perceptions and blah blah
objects etc appearing
and disappearing and appearing and
disappearing
and training the monkey mind to not get
attached
to the clouds themselves but to
recognize myself as the sky
more so the observer or the witness
become more and more aware
of consciousness itself okay so for me i
didn't have those words back then
but that was sort of my yeah my first
step was that
sort of understanding and we'll also
probably talk about entheogens as well
because
both of us have had a good amount of
yeah relation there
so then it in a sense the next
the next step was sort of the it's
really for me it was very
sudden it was it for me this second sort
of step
was basically the complete switch from
being kind of full-time
not aware of the seer to
being boom full-time aware of the seer
aware permanently of the seer aware
permanently of
awareness and how awareness is shared
and eternal
among all of us that was that was the
that was kind of the second thing so
it's like kind of like recognizing sky
versus clouds
and then recognizing oh [ __ ] permanent
sky
is shared in eternal awareness and then
the last one
for me the last step is to recognize
that
even awareness is an agent
of infinity of source expressing itself
and that's sort of recognizing what the
void is or the absolute or the ultimate
is as well as
infinity expressing itself being
completely centerless this atlas
character
and this frank character are in
is are we're in a dream and that these
characters are completely illusory but
also unique
expressions in the dream okay so we're
now yeah walk us through sort of some of
your tennis ball hits along okay
so bouncing back from what you said um
i use an analogy of a video game at
first you're a video game character
you're just a separate avatar
inside the video game and you don't know
that you're in a video game
and in the second step you're the
witness you become the screen and you
start to observe the video game hold the
unconsciousness witness and you stop a
lot of people think they're down there
which is cool that that's
a little bit more spacious because it's
like that's the
sky versus the cloud the first stage and
then the third stage is when
the screen merged with not just the
individual character
but all the characters inside the inside
that game and instead all the infinite
numbers of games in the entire
multiverse uh environment whatever the
sky the clouds
just merge with it so the way i put it
is that you become
the nothing that manifests all games in
all multiverses oh
perfect so it's almost like you pixel
but
that's not really the right analogy
because when you zoom down into a pixel
what do you get you get infinity
so that's the posture path just zooming
and breaking down atoms until you can't
break down atoms anymore that's right
you've been going can you use that
analogy oh you're breaking out atoms by
looking
examining your body monitor you can't
break the artist anymore what is that
that's emptiness
but then it's not it's not like a small
thing here it's not like oh
it's small it's also [ __ ] huge
because the more you can contract your
more you can explain something like you
are like the point that's smaller than
adam but at the same time you are
infinity and the
they're the same so
we're talking about the exact same thing
i think another analogy that i use is
you you at the last stage
you become a cosmic storm
that has no eye i could be high
so there's no center and everything is
rolled into this cosmic storm
in a sort of like impermanent transient
process
even the witness is rolling in there if
the observers wrote in their the self
the big ass the south the small ass
everything's rolling in that cosmic
storm and in that cosmic storm there is
no separate watcher there's no separate
observer and
it's like there is awareness but you're
not present
you transcend both existence
non-existence
oh same analogy uh i love that that was
that was super solid specifically i
loved how you
went through this recognizing on a
video game level which is really
important as an analogy to use here
yeah basically thinking that you are
a separate finite body
entity and you actually use this which i
think i've
started to borrow this from you so good
is the condom
over the head it's oh okay yeah
yeah it's like because i used to be a
sex addict so
that's also so interesting yeah and that
has
been with pick up and body and aesthetic
yeah
yeah yeah yeah and but it is really
it is this is infinity constantly having
sex it's
with itself like you said in the
universe what's up you're [ __ ]
universal
[ __ ] you and you
it's all very sexual this thing is
extremely psycho it's like when people
ask me what does the stainless state of
groundless ground feel like
i'll give them two things one it feels
like death
simultaneously it feels like it feels
like an orgy with the universe
yes without an orgy without a person
yeah every sensation everything you come
across is just penetrating each other
interconnected and it's just like
everything i wanted out of sex
i think i can get it with like the
smaller sensation or the whole room or
you know the sky the car whatever but
sex is still good though
so if you have sex uh it's like a me
it's like a minute of medicine it's like
okay
before you just didn't pick up without
the realization it's just like okay you
just you just okay that's
that's actually the portal to infinity
because if you think about it
um having sex the girl or the guy
you're a girl would be guy they're just
middlemen for you to sort of glimpse at
the absolute because
that's the mini death the orgasm is a
nevada state where your mind just goes
completely blank
that's why most people want to get
orgasms but the point is not to just
get orgasm that's cool too the organ is
kind of like a kundalini awakening but a
lot
like genres or mystical experiences the
real thing that you're trying to get out
of sex
is the post orgasmic bliss that's the
state of equanimity that we're after
everything that we pursue externally for
happiness is giving us glimpses
into yeah what we see and that's why in
the parable of the prodigal
son is the turn rather than seeking
externalities to turn
inward to find as aurobindo said it's
as orbindo said is the well of honey
that's located
under the rock and yeah and the rock is
kind of the ego and as you were saying
there's like this egoic
condom-like bubble in the game character
at first
and not always if you some indigenous
traditions raise
the child from birth in terms of
recognizing infinity expressing itself
and that's really interesting as well is
to think about a pedagogy for kids
so that they don't grow up even having
the egoic condom bubble even to start
but what happens is then yeah the
recognition like you said
of not only being that
screen that then all of the movie plays
on
but also that the screen itself is the
screen for
it's shared for all of the characters
across all
games so it's the you you said this
nothing that
manifests all games so we are
that we are nothing manifesting
all infinite creation and
all games and i and and that's both the
plonk
at the planck level subatomic blah all
the way down
as well as the largest infinite cosmic
yeah yeah and a cosmic storm with no
center is another really good one that
you said
also so it's basically your lila in the
sanskrit tradition you're this
divine play unfolding
and yet you have no
center in that cosmic play that is
unfolding
and because you recognize that you are
it you're not the localization of the
atlas or the frank
it's and you've used this actually this
would probably be a good place to
to go is you said that there's a
solidity
that dissolves and dissolves and
dissolves
and dissolves and dissolves and
dissolves until the last
tiny speck that's that's even
you said there's a difference a quantum
leap difference between 99.9
dissolved and 100 percent dissolved tell
us about sort of
yeah that last spec what you mean
by solidity um and
if that means basically becoming the
nothing that
then manifests infinite creation that's
sort of that last
step that last leap okay so basically
you're doing if you do come from the
postural path basically you skin your
body you're becoming aware of all the
sensations in your body that's the
very basic practice of mindfulness by
skin in the body and that
object of meditation could be the body
it could be the breath
it could be side sound thoughts whatever
it doesn't really matter because all
sensations are equal footing
so let's just say for me as an example
my path was body scanning i did body
skating as a practice for about
uh three years before i started getting
to the other stuff so
what happens is when you become aware as
a meditator as a subject
here meditating to an object outside of
you
it was a duality at first right and the
whole thing about spirituality is
closing that duality between subject and
object
between observed and the observer and
observation
so first when you scan the body you are
breaking down your body atom by atom
it's almost like your body is this onion
and you're peeling it off
layer by layer by layer or just whatever
you want to call it
and just by putting awareness on the
sensation
long enough you automatically dissolve
it and you realize that the awareness
and the sensations are why are the same
and if the body is just a collection of
sensations
if the mind the self is just a
collection of sensations if
side sound emotions are all just
collection of sensations
the more you place your awareness on
those sensations the more you see that
first of all they're not separate
awareness are those sensations since
they are aware of themselves exactly
where they are without a center without
hearing without a seer
but i think it will do it and second of
all
uh you almost physically penetrate those
sensations from solidity to liquid
or honey or nectar
yeah right so but before
you can truly realize everything you
have to first become nothing because
i think affirmation comes after negation
that's why the nadine method
at this not that that's not me not me
why isn't it everything's me
i've talked to a guy uh a few guys told
me why can't i just do this
inquiry practice like this everything's
me that's me the sky is me that's the
self everything is yes
you have to say no to everything before
you can say yes you have to die
completely die
nobody wants to die but everyone wants
to wake up that's what almost says yeah
you have to dissolve every single
solidity not just in your body mind
but in your field of experience through
all the aggregates different scent store
until every single last speck of it is
dissolved
and before you could do that that last
bag even if that spec was the size
size like smaller than atom it's still
going to be quite good itself
that's going to solidify a ground and
for some people that ground or myself
included before i
dissolve the last bag that ground could
be the awareness or the observer or the
godhead
you're gonna personalize the godhead and
say that's the new stuff
if the last deck is there and then it's
not last leg it's the only kind of pull
things
to pull the ground and say that that's
the new me a lot of people
take psychedelics before they dissolve
before they recognize shanata
they they go through the same thing they
they unconsciously
find this stand on just another ground
and say that's the that's the new cell
with the capital s
and let me show you talking about uh
metaphors and analogies
and um visualization because we're both
really into this stuff i have a few
met a few visual metaphors that um that
i saved to
want to show you that really stuff like
stuff yeah stuff like this like you you
have that it's like you can't eat the
i think your your um
viewers will get get a really good sense
of what this thing is like
oh there you go i found it okay so this
is one
this is a good example of it you see
that yeah
yep yeah see and then uh
this one is cool like like something
like that that's that's the really good
example of emptiness and form just
just [ __ ] each other and you know the
possible walls and halls
apart and there's one more that i like
this one i like a lot because
there's no gap there's no it's
completely seamless yeah it's completely
distance to separate because the other
ones are still there's still like a
space inside
that's still not very accurate even
though you could feel like that
it feels like that's how i feel when i
walk around sometimes but that's not
even
that accurate because there's no center
right so before you
close the loop let me turn my camera on
again
okay so the reason i train you guys
because see before you
dissolve the last speck of solidity
infinity can't
comprehend can't know itself there won't
be the clinical perfect knowledge
of know thyself know the lord yeah it's
gonna be
a self knowing the lord instead of the
lord or the self knowing itself
and then people how do i where the lie
is god you just know that's
the most obvious thing it's more obvious
than the fact that you thought you were
a human character before
you woke up so yeah it's just yeah
and then we come across another person
who is sort of
there you just know and people just ask
me how do you know this guy's there that
this
is they just you just know yeah yeah
but of course everyone let me stress
everyone's there already
it's almost like yeah you know here's
another analogy
you're you're you're a vase or an island
in the middle of
the ocean or middle of space and then
you dissolve that island and then just
just washes over you but then there was
never a cup
there was never a cup there was never an
island there was never a base you break
the bay and the
the space inside the base and the space
outside the base has always been
connected
but even that base is made up of empty
space
the difference is degrees of solidity
that's why i keep using it with solidity
the difference between buddha jesus and
a finite con is just a degree of
solidity
the former it could could vibrate
between air uh
liquid or an ice cube if he wants but
what the the the letter the fine icon
could only be an ice cube but the same
no things
so
one of the most common understandings
that you mentioned throughout is
as is talked about across the traditions
is recognizing these
onion layers for those that are really
interested in kind of diving into this
recognizing that
we've identified ourselves dogmatically
fundamentally
culturally become indoctrinated and
baptized into believing that we are the
body we are finite we are our name
we are our form we are are our ethnicity
our age
our career all of these layers of
identity
and so the idea of one of the most easy
fundamental
ideas is to imagine yourself taking
those layers one by one at a time
off until you get to the most pure
bear empty that we share
and that can be thought of as the
awareness before
coloration it's like the blank canvas
before it gets colored like this it's
like the white
shirt before it got colored like this
and it's like your shirt before it got
colored
very similarly and so i i like that i
like how you
you know a really simple way to yeah
there it is i know
there it is yeah i know i know
and then the other thing that you
brought up is that you know one of the
things that people
kind of experience the struggle with in
like the parable the prodigal son to
turn the attention on the seer
itself is because the subtlety
isn't there the sensitivity isn't there
and vipassana you turned it into a verb
the positionalizing
the apostrophizer the propositionalizer
yeah i
i love this pasteurizer
i love that i love that and and this is
it's so good and it's basically like you
said it's
like having your awareness on the cloud
of sensation that's occurring in the
body scans or in the
scans of where the monkey mind is
bouncing around between clouds to where
you get sensitive enough
to where you recognize that the
anisha the impermanence of the cloud or
of the
uh even as goenka says that tiniest
little biochemistry that's happening and
then
gone and and so that's
that's critical to sort of people it's
so interesting it's like when you play a
you play the violin which is also
interesting i played the viola when i
was a kid
and and so what's interesting is that
you can't expect just like when you go
and play
you know basketball too you can't walk
out and begin
shooting three-pointers and sinking all
of them
so in a sense same with vipassana
it's almost like it's a muscle
yeah that we have to train because
otherwise it gets atrophied
the muscle of be of recognizing oneself
as the seer
it gets atrophied if we don't uh
do the the repetitions the workout and
so that's that's been another critical
uh part of that too so so basically
would you say that
in a sense the dissolving
of the ego is very very
gradual gradual gradual repetitions
repetitions
and then there are these both the sudden
also
breakthroughs that happen that that then
we kind of
you kind of re-baseline to that as home
of being the seer the seer becomes the
home
and then that's that's a level of
subtlety
away from the gross physical and then
the sort of that becomes home for a
while and then you also
kind of recognize that then even
awareness is an agent of
infinity and you can kind of shed even
that to this nothingness to this
void itself that is then expressing
infinite creation and then and then
you're no longer
there's no center anymore it's just that
massive like you showed in the visuals
and then that's kind of the highest you
could say level of subtlety
rather than the gross physical
something around that style of increase
in subtlety
is that the subtlety dissolves the the
grossness the physicalness
yes okay before we go on let's
i want to clarify for the people
watching when you say seer
um you're talking about the infinity
that's expressing itself
you're talking about the awareness
without the observer yeah because people
can get confused because when i talk
about the scene
i always say there's no seer there's no
seer there's no here that the buddhist
term is saying it that you
hear the hearing and seeing just the
thing in thinking just the thing is not
thinking no see
no here so let's just define that really
quick uh
so when you say c is the co the capital
x
it's the absolute witness without
separate observers okay cool and when i
say see here if i ever use the words
here i mean like the individual seer
that's speaking out from behind your
eyes which doesn't exist that's the
thing
interesting and like ramana maharshi
said that you know god is the seer so
like recognize that it's the capital s
versus when you say you sometimes mean
like the lowercase
s yeah like okay okay also the term
awareness
also needs to be clarified because uh
when when
that's why the distinction between
awareness and uh
well there like i said before there is
awareness but
you're not present so there's no
individual uh
observer you can if you can objectify
anything then
if you can observe anything then by
definition you're not the observer
so you can observe the observer if you
can be aware of awareness if you could
be conscious
or even god consciousness then by
definition you're none of those things
and that's when you disappear into what
i call the one blanket of the universe
those things still are can still be
experienced there's experience
experience in itself
but that's very i think the
very big distinction between
experiencing awareness or experiencing
god consciousness
as as an individual self in a center
versus
experiencing experiencing itself without
the experiencer
which means that all the stages before
oh yeah you can you can deconstruct and
dissolve the observer the awareness
the consciousness the bride even the
brown you can do some all that
but they're still there but you are just
not there
but the experience of it is there
there's a very big difference between
experiencing that without us
in the yourself versus still having part
of that experience but you're
solidifying into
the ego mine that's a very subtle
distinction that a lot of people
don't get but it's the difference is
huge
that's basically the difference between
the screen and
becoming the screen and the video game
at the same time
yeah okay so let's let's put that
into the description in the game
in the game analogy so it would be
that i am a separate at the lowest level
i am a separate
finite player in the game
and then it's in a sense recognizing
that i am the awareness
itself that is the experiencer
of not only this game but of beyond this
game
and then kind of recognizing that that
awareness is shared in eternal
that's sort of becoming more and more
the screen itself that's modulating the
different
images of that game and the next games
that come up
so from being the finite player in the
game to being the screen
and then in sort of the the the last
in a sense stage is both the
is both the absolute nothingness as well
as the absolute
everythingness right right okay exactly
the screen merger with the game and the
characters
and but but but so basically well
the the re yeah there's there's a screen
at the third level
this screen because the screen would be
analogous to having the
the the observer the separate observer
that's watching your thoughts
that would be the screen that's the
thing that that's the passionalizer that
we're trying to be passionate about
the observer that we're trying to
observe so we can deconstruct
yeah because what the observer is really
is just
more solidified sensations that's
clustered around
it's you know either here you know you
know behind your eyes and your head
or you know it could be it could be like
a giant experience
where it's like you know it's like all
boundless space but it's still
there's still a bubble there there's
still a solidity there and
the point is dissolve all solidity not
just in the hair not just outside but
everything so but before you can
dissolve the solidity
this the solidity is always going to
congeal itself into a new ground and
sort of rapidly itself so it's very
tricky it's very very tricky
yeah that's it's very frank says frank
says the ego is a cheeky [ __ ]
it's a cheeky gun so even
solidity solidity is a cheeky [ __ ] and
it'll come back
yeah you'll come back yeah but then
after you've dissolved everything
there are still going to be experiences
where you can feel a little bit more
solidified to the next
but you see or you experience them
experientially at the cellar that's
empty you could still have conditions
arise
due to everyday you know interaction
with you know with some kara but you
realize sakura
we both i think we both just cut out for
a moment let's just rewind
a couple sentences keep going from the
it's from the cheeky cutness of the
of the solidity coming back go ahead
okay
so yeah okay what i was saying was after
realization you could still have
solidity coming back
due to everyday interaction with the war
of some power but realize some kara is
nirvana you see at the most
cellular fundamental level that solidity
and emptiness are saying
there's an absolute difference and
because of this realization
your experience of solidity just goes
down by 99.99
yeah yeah so and this is also where
science is
holograms everything as holograms yeah
science holograms
and science has been a really fun in the
last 100 years
sort of you know donald hoffman called
science that johnny come
lately to the spiritual mystic tradition
i love you guys
yeah he's so spot on johnny completely
because um
because even quantum mechanics is saying
that yeah it's
no thing that is then modulating
and appearing as matter and form
and then to recognize that voidness that
nothingness as well as the
everythingness
there's just nothing outside of that
that that's
it there's there's
even a difference between dimensions
people are like oh are we living in a
simulation
how about the 5d dimension versus the 2d
i said there's no distinction
yes it's all nothing that's manifesting
as form that's just different
in form yeah yeah yeah
probably just trying to take credit for
infinity just like
what is that what's the self you're just
so literally taking credit pretending
for a second
that it's nothingness and that could be
manifest into
either the egoic self or you know the
observer or the god
self but all this is labels yeah
yeah and there's the idea of
wherever fascinatingly enough simulation
theory is is taking us which is so
awesome is just another in a sense
johnny come lately to the spiritual
mystic wisdoms which is basically now in
a synthesis of
of science and engineering and
technology with spirituality
can say that it doesn't even matter what
layer or what
nesting hurdle we're talking about
because it's
all the that nothingness to that
everythingness
and yeah so so yeah so
so so what um we just like we're about
to do
right now frank we fast forward like 10
years or 20 years
it's just gonna be a myriad of these
kind of like indistinguishable virtual
realities
where you know you'll pop in for you
know and play a game
and then you'll you know you'll switch
into a different game
on a potentially even a different planet
different civilization different
timeline
different blah blah and just jump
between these
simulations and and whatnot and and
guess what stays the same
the agent of observation what stays the
same
just like in the dream at night when you
go to sleep and you simulate out the
dream
environment is very similar to what the
manifested virtual
reality world is like you know we
simulate out the observing agent
and we simulate out the dreamed
environment in in the dream world
and so you know yeah so i i find that
all of that wisdom of dreams and
video game simulations are all
a way to express the nothingness to the
everythingness
the void to the infinitude is that about
how you feel
yeah yep the see the difference between
well i think dream and reality or
different diamond
is again difference in solidity but once
you realize it's all empty you can play
around with different degrees of
solidity
so the only reason why i think this most
people before realization think this
reality right here is critical real and
that the dream is a dream is because
dream is less solid
dream is more liquid it's more you know
there's more uh
we walk around without consequences you
know
because it's just more liquidy it's less
solidified right and this reality is
more solidified but it's it's just the
degree of it the same
thing that makes up the dream in this
world and if it was discovered that
there's another dimension out there and
we've
simulated dimension it's just gonna be
the same it's just gonna be the
different configurations of solidity
and different degrees of the solidity
but all solidity
are exactly the same as non-solidity
anyway
yeah so yeah and it's it's the same with
psychedelics actually psychedelics are a
great tool
of the rick bob they have a glimpse of
the the absolute witness or the uh
uh the the the awareness without the
observer it's it's a great way to
glimpse it
but but the content of psychedelics is
just a solidity of it the manifestation
of the emptiness
so if you get caught up in psychedelics
caught up in the form without realizing
that the form the context the content of
the context are exactly the same
then you could be chasing down a rabbit
hole that you never
like you could be chasing more it's like
more ultra state of consciousness it's
going to be more and more but
alignment is not really a level of
consciousness it's that which gives rise
to all levels of consciousness
in mind yeah which doesn't exclude
anything by the way it's not like oh let
me just think
top here because i saw this diagram
yesterday um david hawkins
uh oh yeah the levels of consciousness i
saw you comment about that
on your story he's been he's been a
profound
influence on on me as well but
uh go ahead because that was i think
that was your first time sort of
seeing the way that he had put it and so
uh yeah yeah it's been it's been a
really powerful influence on
many people awakening to sort of what
these elevated states of peace joy bliss
as a natty state as a natural state are
and how even all this ego and the shame
and guilt
and all that stuff are nowhere near
as much of uh
of a natty state yeah let me let me pull
it out
let me pull it out so people can see
there we go i think a lot of people have
seen this grab the states of
consciousness
you have enlightenment at the top
enlightenment at the top then you have
peace joy
love reason acceptance willingness
neutrality courage pride anger desire
and i can't read the rest but the last
one is shane um
consciousness level i mean it's really i
mean it's a great graph um i don't
honestly i don't know that much about
david hawkins but just from the
i've seen some i've i've read some of
the texts that people send me
yeah this guy got some real wisdom uh
and the the graph
sometimes i like to pick like nitpick
little things just to make people think
outside the box
i'm not saying that graph is wrong like
i would put it that way too but
it's more like enlightenment is not
really at the top of the pyramid it's
more like the space
that gives rise to the entire pyramid
yeah
it concentrates all the levels and that
just because you're at the
enlightenment level or the knowing level
environment doesn't mean that you can
never feel shame
that's just [ __ ] you can still feel
everything
all the range of human emotion you can
feel but after enlightenment
you feel them from a completely
different perspective
and the suffering really that all the
mystic traditions
they really deliver what they preach
they really deliver well to advertise
my goal was never to eliminate suffering
i just wanted to understand experience
and consciousness but after the path
or at least where i am right now i'll
take there's more but it's
the more for me right now it's like
going back after you beat the video game
i have jiggled
yeah yeah yeah delivery you deliver
rare candies to all everybody like in
pokemon you're delivering rare candies
to help people
level up the bodhisattva the tantric
weave
of your realizations um one of the one
of the things that you mentioned
there that's really important is sort of
the
uh there's a spiral dynamics as well
from
claire graves and don beck and chris
cowan and even ken wilbur
and that spiral dynamics has a very
similar style of understanding as like
levels of consciousness
and at the top of the spiral dynamics is
also
that state of which you become the
integration
of yeah exactly yeah and
and the mystic traditions what they
teach is they basically teach in a sense
they teach
the pause you you create this pause
there's this gap
that you create now so that you no
longer
react instantly to the different stimuli
and get absorbed in the clouds but
instead
that pause that gap that you create
through breath
through that on a panel that awareness
what happens is
is that then you observe
the arising of the cloud of anger or
shame or guilt or whatever
and then you go i've i already know what
this is all about i'm just bringing
bliss peace
love joy right period and so then it's
sort of yeah getting
into that you re-baseline yourself more
and more
towards that and so this is why i
i i struggle a bit with
neo advaita teachings because
the neo advice of pointing is that
you know you're you're already it you're
all it's the non-dual real
you're already it you're already the as
roomie said you go from room to room
looking for the diamond that is already
around your neck
and and yet the sufi traditions they
say yet it remains for you to recognize
it
it remains for you to recognize it and
the buddha
from 2500 years ago taught a very
systematic science to eradicating
the suffering because you no longer
attach yourself in the cloud so very
much so in the neo advaita
if you just say this is all a dream i'm
an illusion
this is all a dream and there's nothing
for me to do there's nothing to seek i'm
already it
then the ego the condom bubble in a
sense
may not ever have gotten popped and so
you may actually still butterfly effect
out malevolence
because you haven't went through the
process that maybe the buddha
had taught for a while how do you feel
about stuff like that
um that's what i think you need to uh
tag
to skin infinity from all different
angles
yes that's what i was saying about what
i was saying earlier
that a lot of people could get glimpses
of the non-dual state either by
practicing you know
you know advaita stuff or psychedelics
but if they haven't
with their industrial strength
concentration sit down
shut the [ __ ] up go to retreats dissolve
their entire field of experience and
that takes time that takes time it's not
like it's a glimpse of it
so you need to attack infinity from both
sides until it close the loop on itself
so i agree with that it's almost like
you as a video game character
you can sort of have a cheat call for a
little bit and then realize on the
screen
but then without actually dissolving
your solidity
uh like a bodybuilder wrap a wrap
wrapper wrap
day by day uh year by year you're going
to go back to ego itself
and a lot of times when you have a
glimpse of it you actually become even
more egoic
because you're extrapolating that
experience you had into the new grounds
and yourself
into the new the character goes around
telling all the characters hey i'm the
screen on the screen but
there's still a separation between him
in the screen or else he wouldn't be
saying that
right yeah yeah so
i i really appreciate how you keep
saying not only
tackling it from all these different
sides and angles as we talked about with
polymothy
but also we've been using this gym
analogy a lot the repetitions which is
great
and also you say closing the loop i
really like how you say
and you use the douglas hofstetter
strange loop
uh as well i really like that because
that's ultimately what these
uh potent you know potential big bang
big crunches big bangs big branches
are yeah yeah and
it's looping on itself without beginning
to end and the universe is a big
sensation it's just
different degrees they just messed it up
i love that the universe is a big
sensation of
yeah of having sex with yeah
oh man uh so yeah about the
the non-duality stuff i think just also
at the other side of the stream a lot of
people can't get stuck in the emptiness
stuff
they can get stuck in the buddha stuff
i've seen people that go to
passing on retreats over and over again
for 10 years 20 years
they haven't realized they're they're a
meditator inside the head
yeah i know i know
okay keep going
again like if you can just tell those
people dude man relax a little bit
do some headless way stuff you know
listen to some newman
that's that would you know that's why
when i tell my fitness client
you know what is power power is speed
times strength right
so as an athlete like a sprinter a
sprinter runs fast because he has a lot
of power he has both speed and strength
because sprinting is not just pure speed
it's power
so if you want to be a good sprinter you
have to lift weights
strong in the squats and you have to do
some plyometric stuff
box jumps reactivity stuff like and then
you transfer that into power speed times
trading is power a lot of people only
have one side of the equation and you
just need to do a little bit more off
the other side of the creation people
that are really going to be passionate
and really good
at concentration stuff they're like
strength athletes they're like they have
a lot of
the strength but they're not
transferring that strength into speed
speed is more like the the zoho chain
type of the parametrics
of the mind it's more like you know the
headphones will glimpse the where the
weight is practice we just kind of
you know sort of like you know turn your
waist on itself snap a finger
that's the speed of the awareness and
then you the passion of the
concentration in the strength
times the speed the problems of the mind
you go you get a power athlete and
awakening is power
yes yes yeah that's that's great
that's why yeah
that's why um sheila samadhi and panya
are sort of these three buddhist
style principles that are so fundamental
you have to have the morality the
morality is critical because the
morality
and the awakening feedback on
each other they do the more moral you
are the more easy it is to awaken the
more awakened you get the more easy it
is to be moral
right and so you get that feedback and
then the concentration has a lot to do
with
actually being able to calm yourself
down to the economy
to be able to see the clouds forming and
dissolving the anisha there the
impermanence
and then you get the panya you get the
insight
you get the vipassana in the sense the
true
insight into the nature of reality and
being
when you kind of do enough
repetitions and you also do poly math
you go and you do repetitions here
and you do repetitions here and you do
and you do you know you do these kinds
of repetition and you do you know
yeah you exactly yeah you have you work
out the whole
body right you don't there's so many
bodybuilders that will only do chest
right but you've got to do your legs
also
right that's that's a huge funny meme in
the aesthetics bodybuilding
world and it's the same thing here as
well if you don't
know the how um uh
um a micro dose of magic mushrooms will
uh will interplay with
the realizations that you've that you've
had so far with your weightlifting
that that that's that's it's that's its
own style of
of of you know that's its own style of
weightlifting
and dance and so you you gain all these
different styles of dance and art
to form this masterpiece the the sufi
metaphysics have a
have a the phrase it goes
it means it means the unity of
all finding right the unity of
all
infinity closing the loop on itself
you can yeah you can enter that you can
close the loop any way you want really
exactly and that's the thing there's
unique styles
it's the unique styles that's why that's
why wadat al-wujud is so important
because
every single expression of infinity
has its own unique style of closing the
loop on itself
that's why you have your own unique
style of
realizing the one end and
this expression has its unique style of
closing the loop
and so that's what that's why that's
what
i understand as the reason why leela
happens
is the big game of hide and seek the big
game of realization for infinity to go
through
do you how does that feel so
that see a lot of people ask if
awakening is the same and everyone are
different it's both different and the
same because the difference arise
through the unity it's neither just
unity because you say oh there's only
oneness there's only unity that's the
ground right there that's an extreme
you take the middle way the middle way
is that which transcends the dualities
right so it's both neither unity or
separateness they call dependent or rice
so everybody's experience of emptiness
is the same
but how you fill that emptiness with
form is different reconfigurations of it
for everybody
but then at the same time emptiness is
formed so
it's always going to be the same and
different and each
a lot of people like i love jim newman
but i find that
some of the non-duality stuff that are
too extreme a little bit unsettling for
people that are still on the path
it is true that there's nothing to do it
is today you don't even
need to meditate because no meditation
no
johnic states uh can touch infinity
there's just gonna be like little
mosquito dancing on infinity even
the most mind-blowing psychedelic
experience but
if you tell people that there's nothing
to do when they're still on the path
that's a good reminder
once in a while but i've never met
anybody except for maybe one out of
five million geniuses that didn't have
to do anything to
wake up even though it is your true
nature
so um what was it going with that i was
talking about something else before that
well we were talking about those unique
styles and i just i think
a really good way to hit the ball back
on what you were just saying is the
simultaneity
which is really important i i feel
there's a lot of people that sort of get
stuck and i think
bentino's also mentioned this before as
well it's almost like the non-duality
police
it's like it's it's only non-duality
period
and yes and simultaneously
is the dualistic concession where
there yeah where you do have the egoic
bubble over people's
heads the condom and that there is a
process of popping that
condom bubble that people are walking
around in
and that's what the mystic traditions
teach as these gym repetitions to do
that
and then also another part of the
dualistic concession
is what is taught in physics as well
with
electromagnetism and it's also taught
with that rhythmic
balanced interchange between the forces
and that's what was called the gunas as
well in the sanskrit
you have you have these most fundamental
units that create the ascension that
happens
of uh what's happened in the billions of
years that has gotten us to the point
where
infinity can be recognizing why it's
here doing what it's doing
and yeah and so um so that was critical
the simultaneity is also i'm curious to
see
what you feel about this i think it's
really important but it'll be
interesting to see how you feel
about it is that um sometimes the
the jim newman and tony parsons and neo
advanta
can can they there can be sometimes this
very
blunt like the the individual is
only a complete illusion and dream uh
you don't exist
that's it done and and that that kind of
that doesn't take in to account the
simultaneity or the jedi-like ability to
go from
um all of the phases of water from the
steam the vapor
um to the the the boiling
and the water at the room temperature
and slowly becoming ice the
e the egoic ice so the point of that
point is to say that
simultaneity can be thought of in a
sense as non-duality as the ultimate and
then the dualistic concession
like we were just talking about a moment
ago and then the individuation
is is seen as both a
dream as an illusion there being no
center
at the same time as being a unique
firework
like infinity makes these fireworks
so that we can have this firework about
itself and yeah and so and so that's why
you it's instead of completely saying
[ __ ]
all the form the form is an illusion
[ __ ] all the form
instead of saying that it's basically
the east telling the west that it's
wrong
but that's not how i see i see the east
and the west as coming together
as one so you're both the non-dual east
and you're the western beautiful
individuated firework of infinity how do
you feel about that
exactly because what there's nothing off
limit with infinity infinity has to
include
did not define right the infinity has to
include the individual
right so who is it that says there's no
june newman
jim newman
with big letters jim newman there's
nobody here
[Laughter]
no i'm not i'm not i love jim newman i
really love the guy i like
people like that we need people like who
are the ones that are extreme to tell
people to tell the people who are doing
a lot of vipassana without realizing
that
why isn't it to say hey man
what did you do we need to like that but
i'm sure he realizes i'm sure that's
part of his the way he's that's part of
his critical brand
i'm sure he realizes it but but that's
how he chooses to express infinity
and the way we choose to express
infinity is that we emphasize the form
with the emptiness not over the
emptiness but with emptiness
yeah so i think you know i think that
view it's about
it's about the reflexivity of the view
you can
both and simultaneously be a person and
not be a person
depends on the situation beyond
conditions there's no reason to think
that
no cell view is the ultimate view
because style you're staring at
underground but then again you have to
realize that you be
before you can say that's not the only
ground right
so you have to realize it first and then
you have that lever to play around with
but then at that point after you realize
no cell when you have a coordinate cell
when you have
when you continue into a character it
doesn't feel like itself anymore
yeah would you
would you then use the word you know
simultaneity
as the sort of one of the best ways to
explain this
okay yeah yeah i think so i think so
because
even rob berbia uh he wrote a book
called emptiness uh
scene singing a freeze the whole book is
about emptiness
but he keeps emphasizing that when
emptiness is in even the distinction
between illusion and
reality is in and the self an illusion
even fabrication is a fabrication
because if everything is a fabrication
and nothing's fabrication if everything
is a dream nothing's a dream
right so even he said that
it's very even though he emphasizes no
self and emptiness a lot
even he said that's just one view out of
infinite numbers of views that you can
have
as this the infectible
inevitable so
he said that it's not it's not exactly
healthy to just
apply it in the no self view 24 7
because then that's when you get a
spiritual bypass you know and then it's
very easy to becoming
an [ __ ] yeah when you're just
operating i'm not non-dual 24 7 no
self-state
it's also very easy to be an athlete
when you're only in the self-egoic state
exactly why i am
bringing up simultaneity because when
you
because buddha today would
be in a sense uh if people were solely
saying
that this is emptiness dancing there's
nothing for me to do
period then that would be the buddha you
know
saying that listen you know there's a
way
literally for you to end suffering for
yourself and not just say that it's
emptiness dancing i can be an egoic
malevolent [ __ ] if it you know
there's a way to
calm that down to water that flame fire
yeah
so i'm i'm glad yeah the simultaneity
and then another way to
talk about that is like a jedi a jedi
the jedi knows how to be at all of these
layers yeah that's another good way
shape-shifting
or another good way is um the biblical
story of
joseph and the code of many colors as
well it's
it's like the shape shifter and um
so there's a lot of octopus it's like a
cosmic octopus
the cosmic octopus that's interesting
where did that where'd you get that one
from
well i first got that from i used to
like uh octopus a lot because i heard
uh i heard this talk by terence mckinnon
yeah it turns me kenna said um he said
like he really liked the octopus because
the octopus is not it's sort of he
didn't
he said the octopus wears his mind or
his thoughts
on his body he turns the inside out
and the outside in so the octopus's body
his identity is a reflection of the
environment
and he's constantly shape-shifting and
then i took that analogy a bit further
and we said that
this state right here the state of the
stateless data state or whatever this is
it feels like you are a cosmic octopus
with no body with no center
so it's almost like this the buddha with
like a thousand arms and a thousand eyes
yeah there's none you have this 360
generating vision
and you have those tentacles that are
like not
did every sensation even the cops
outside the clouds the cars are here
even you seeing you
um there's just different tentacles of
sensations just looping back on itself
and i like that so i like that
it's it's just like yeah yeah it's so in
a sense
the cosmic octopus is kind of like when
the tentacles are out
everywhere imaginable in all of the
infinite creation
and yet is also the void i see the span
the cosmic octopus can be thought of as
the span
whereas the jedi or shape shifter or
just from the kodi many colors
it's across all the layers
simultaneously
that's that's that's that's that's the
core i think there
and then would it be
would it be fair then to say
it it would be fair to say that on
repeat
were just void to form
form to void infinite amount here
let me also um let me also put it this
way
um how many
different ways can you color a blank
canvas
different numbers of ways how many
different ways can you arrange musical
notes into a song
different numbers of ways how many
different ways can you vibrate your
vocal chords to make language
different numbers of ways how many
different ways can you modulate
a movie screen to make movies
different numbers of ways and so this is
the this is
i think this has been the most easy way
for me when i talk to people because as
soon as i start asking them those
questions
they almost get glimpses into infinity
right as i'm asking them the questions
that's very interesting man
i think we're coming we're talking about
the same thing but in a different
from different sides you're talking
about like the
impermanent like every moment is
different kind of side i'm talking about
like
the physicality of like the looping of
it but they're the same
yeah but they're the same so so it's
almost like it's
okay so when people ask you to describe
what the rig pie is or the natural state
is you can't give it a description at
all because
it's like what the natural state is it's
like
you get a second different green tea you
get a different psychedelic from a
different planet every national second
that's what i have to realize different
psychedelic from a different
planet every nanosecond oh my god
okay keep going so you can tell after
realization it's just like
trippy bro you don't you never know what
you're gonna get the next moment
even though it's already like that but
before you tend to solidify experiences
into into boxes but not without a box
really every [ __ ] moment is
that's no [ __ ] cool i'm gonna do next
it's so exciting it's just like
oh my gosh i can't i can't stop thinking
about this
okay so we were just talking about all
of the different ways you can color
a blank canvas or arrange musical notes
into a song
so you got to think about all the
different ways that we could create
a planet orbiting a star that would then
secrete
the entheogens and psychedelics and also
the
humans that would then eat them and
whatnot and so you're saying that
every single nanosecond you're basically
taking
a different entheogen psychedelic from a
different
creation a different planet secretion
and eating that and experiencing that
profound of a state of
of voidness to infinity is
that and that's emptiness and form is
infinite empty
you find deforming emptiness is
emptiness in form yeah and that dance is
yeah yeah the heart structure yeah the
heart suture knew it
i i really like the way that um that
that was described that
that is basically in essence what it is
it's like a kundalini
it's like a permanent kundalini um
toriel awakening like you were sort of
showing in those different
visualizations on on the device it's
almost like
you live it's like everybody lives
in that cosmic storm
um feeling but only those that have
quote awakened or enlightened
basically become full-time
aware of the that notion of the
centerless
insanity of lila cosmic storm whereas
when you live on the gross condom level
you don't recognize that because you're
not subtle enough um
to recognize it because the universe has
it as it [ __ ] itself
that you're doing it with this condom
over your head and so you're not getting
any of the sensation of
that yeah of something
oh my gosh oh my god that was so good a
difference
i wrote i actually wrote down a few
analogies i want to share with you
because
yeah let's do it let's do it so i'll
throw it out at the analogy hour for you
and you can you know hit the tennis ball
back
okay so number one is we talked about it
an
invisible cosmic octopus with no body
um and second one is called okay hold on
let's let's start with there so
so one moment so the invisible cosmic
octopus
with no body with no center okay and
then what was that what's the second one
the second one is that we i think we
talked about this very also as the
cosmic storm without an eye
oh that was a good one too cosmic storm
without an eye
yeah okay and the third one the thousand
eye
and on buddha
and armed buddha have you seen that
you've seen those sculptures
the statues right yeah with all of the
the arms
and then it has a hair on the head and
the head on the head and all the
different heads like
360 but then e360 also has another back
another effect all of
a really good uh physical uh
visualization
artistic uh representation of the state
i would say of infinity that's great
and and you're aware the mandelbrot
infinite fractal zoom right benoit
mandelbrot
fractal zoom yeah yeah i saw it i think
i saw it in some of your your
work that i tell people
straight up when they want to know what
the state is like is just check out the
video if not
infinite
so yeah and then those visuals are some
of it some of them some of this stuff
the klein bottle the klein bottle is
another one with the mobius
prime bottle i don't know if
k-l-e-i-n bottle oh yeah there we go
yeah yeah yeah totally that's a great
that's another one
yeah and that that that kind of in that
does
really the toriel style of big bang big
crunch
yeah yeah so it's like with the
different colors you can fill in there
that's the other one bro yeah that's the
one that air
specifically eric weinstein has been a
big proponent of
of that one um are you familiar with his
work eric weinstein
i've heard of his name but i i don't
think i've ever listened to him
he's kind of pretty ninja-like around
the math and the physics
around infinity also which is
interesting you know who garrett lisi
is he's another one that's kind of um
they're they're both on kind of the math
and physics around
infinity expressing itself um and then
um yeah when we talked about the
beginning of the conversation before we
go live it's like a lot of those
smart guys the physicists the artists
even drug addicts
the writers they're at the edge of
enlightenment even kanye west i think
yep they're at the edge of their mind
but they don't have the proper
techniques
to transcend it that's what also said
beethoven
sartre regina wolf um all those guys
need to eat all these guys will be
enlightened beans if they were to from
the west oh sorry from the east yep but
in today's world we have the perfect
opportunity to enlightenment because we
have to eat this
internet internet exactly
address your what you were what you
brought up a moment ago but you're so
right
that there's a in a sense it's kind of
like what we can do in service
to the awakening is we can play the
tennis
with these different leaders which we'll
talk about more
uh afterward um a briefly on on the call
but just the idea is that if we can take
infinity expressing itself
to the leadership around the world like
um there's 2 200 billionaires around the
planet and there's
you know 225 000 ultra high net worth
people are on the planet and there's
200 people in the u.n general assembly
fortune 500 ceos 535 people in u.s
congress
basically the point is that there's all
these different world leaders that have
a butterfly effect
out on so many people around the planet
and so one of the things that we can do
is that if we can enter into dialectic
with them
whether it be you know kanye west is a
good one where like you were describing
there's so many people on this
brink and that to sort of
um help them recognize it in the most
child-like
analogies is um a massive part of the
gift
um to bring so that that's a critical
one that i think we'll talk about more
afterward i really like what you were
saying um i think um this is probably a
way that
uh you and i will end up collaborating
on is helping
the visualization of the nature of
reality
um have you also seen the um
have you seen alex gray's art yeah i
think
his stuff also comes very close to some
of this yes and you know the net of
being
that one it's like indra's net the net
of being
it has all of the different um heads
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that one yeah right there and it's like
what you were saying with that
thousand-eyed um yeah
so so i like these visualizations i
think that's a good one the cosmic storm
without an
eye is a really good one as well um
and it's another one yeah
what what was the last one god
djing itself oh god djing
itself like disc jockeying music
yeah yeah that's a good one yeah yeah
that's a good idea
okay here's another one that you like i
think this is another one a sculpture
sculpting itself until the clear light
of awareness appears it looks like
michael angelo you know how he said the
form of the sculpture is already inside
the bark marble
and you just need to chip away the
unnecessary uh
parts of it and then we're doing that
with spirituality we're sculpture
sculpting ourselves and then inside the
sculpture
is the clear lab wellness that's
infinite and boundless and the funny
thing is
speciality is the only thing that you
have the only task
the only task you can do where you can
have your cake and eat it too i would
say spirituality
you have your cake and you eat it too
you can still pick up you can still do
bodybuilding you know
that's the only thing that you can do
where you can become shredded and
buffed at the same time you straight
yourself into an atom smartly out of it
but at the same time
you gain your your dhamma body of
infinity into
uh absolute infinite space you get
shredded
and you you you you can cut at the same
time
yeah yeah that's that's a good way to
put it
is that you um and that's sort of what i
meant by like what that aloo jude when i
kind of had my like little profound
um in december this um
kind of like a macro level satori was a
it was very much like seeing the entire
planet
undergoing the process of that like you
described the
sculptor sculpting itself until
the enlightened or awakened recognition
of the
loop of infinity closing on itself
in that recognition and so that was yeah
that was
i think that one's really profound i
agree that it's like having your cake
and eating it too god djing itself was
good
um so we'll we'll have to keep
artistically also
i would another thing is um
if you can and i know you're already
doing this in you know in a sense but
um taking and constantly you know
visualizing this
more and more on your channels
and disseminating the visualizations
more and more and so we'll we'll do
because i mean we're making
animated series we're making um
long-form content as well short form
content
i always wanted to do that yeah we're i
feel like we're going to end up
um collaborating on that as well you're
uh
you have about a
couple dozens of minutes you have like a
dozen minutes left
so because you need a little bit of time
to get to your um
uh your appointment
the appointment is at 12 30 so i could
probably end at 12 or maybe a little bit
exactly and be good okay cool so let's
wrap with
oh i got a couple more visuals that one
do it do it let's do it a couple more
couple more one of them is
uh your body mine your meat suit
and all the objects that you perceive
the clouds and the trees even the floor
are become mosquitos they're just
mosquitoes flying around
the infinite bra
oh interesting the so everything
is like mosquitoes flying around the
infinite bra
yeah so basically before you were the
mosquito
before you were only the mosquito but
now after you shift perspective
to the dharmakaya to the dharma body of
infinite bra
all the organization your entire body by
pre-awakening
even the the cars outside the
house the buildings all become so small
because you have to get people to
visualize it
you know it's like yeah you you
literally
you knew i did becomes the sky and all
this all these different
objects in the world are just mosquitoes
flying around your new diamond body
but at the same time there's no
distinction again because the the
the mosquitoes are just emptiness
vibrating into the form
they're made up the same thing as the
skies and the clouds and the trees yeah
so i think that that would be animation
that's a tricky one
yeah that's another good one
okay okay uh there's one more there's
one more
this one i think is pretty similar to
the kind of energy that you had on your
channel when you said um the necklace
it's like having a hundred dollar bills
in your pocket
all the time you're just pulling one out
after another like endlessly every time
every day you say every time you want a
glimpse at the absolute you just pull
out
a bit it's always different endless
so it's kind of like the infinite wallet
or whatever
yeah pretty much the infinite wall
this is great okay i like this
i like this a lot yeah i feel i feel
like it's
super bringing it to the child like
level of playful
visual understanding which we definitely
it it's go it'll accelerate yeah the
visualization's going to accelerate
and amplify yeah big time big time
that's the core
that i've noticed by the way the
geniuses
that have lived before now
they've been focused on that deeply as
well is
visualizing the refined
distillations of metaphysics
the einstein was a visual artist man
like his general theory of relativity
it's all about visualization
his thought experiments because humans
are visionary animals and why do you say
the scene all cni the whisper eye
this whole thing is about a way of
seeing a way of perception
even though even though awareness goes
beyond just seeing
it but it's almost like there's just one
unified sensor
and it's this all thing eye that
transcends
any individual or specific sense or like
the visual sense or like the audio sense
the awareness in a way it's kind of like
just god's eye
god's eye without an eye the awareness
yeah
it's a theme that goes beyond scene
anyway so there's another there's two
more that i think
you're gonna like this one have you seen
pacific rim like the movie pacific rim
yeah yeah it's probably been a bit but
yep okay
so it's like it's like uh it's kind of
like this the entire
um
so it's like this dude i'll read what i
wrote
it's kind of like the robot you become
the giant robot suit in pacific rim
except that this suit is the entire
cosmo with absolutely no gap and no
separation and distance between humans
objects in the sky mountains moon and
the sun and all its parts are working
harmony
and doing its best to make every action
you perform and every thought that you
have an acid perfection
in an interconnected interdependent way
and there's no driver
inside the the robot as it's just doing
itself as itself
okay okay so i i like it
so in a sense sense it can be
interchangeable the pacific rim analogy
can be potentially interchangeable with
maybe the avengers
with the like the superheroes um
style recognize that you are the
infinite bra
superhero type thing um yeah
and and that um and that there's no
separation in the cosmic storm of
infinite bra superheroes
yeah yeah it's just one superhero with
different parts
and this one i think it's good for
representing like the interconnectivity
of it like
the the origination of it how like
every event has like an infinite wax of
conditions that connect to different
different website conditions because the
zoo is kind of like
it's like oh
i like doctor octopus too yup
doctor dr octopus looks like the
thousand buddha
do we should come up with the [ __ ]
like infinite bra superhero that just
like embodies all the stuff that we're
talking about i agree
i agree that's another really good one
it's like
the in the in the the the infinite bra
superhero is a really good way i'll tell
you why
the psychological literature is really
clear
that young kids really love
superheroes a lot they and so if we
make this infinite bra superhero when we
make this
and then yeah it's it's really good it's
a really good idea
it's like it's like mom mom dad i want
to be
the infinite bra yeah
yes yes yes yes but then it's really
important to not
to just make sure that it's not
externalized like like that's
the infinite bra superhero not not me
i'm not that yeah exactly yeah you know
you have to realize that we're all iron
man
or whatnot yeah yeah type thing yeah we
all of it but none of it
yeah yes yes and that's why that's why
it leads me to my last
example uh woman for which is uh you are
just an
invis you're you're an invisible man
like the the the the invisible main
character from
from the uh world you're just a
invisible man but all the sensations the
side the close buildings the trees that
the floor
the people are just the clothes that you
slap on they're just like the masks that
you wear
yep yep so even your body your ego your
your mind other people's thoughts every
since
you experienced an entire war are just
clothes that you put on even space and
time
and awareness and observers different
clothes that you slap on
and this this bean is invisible yeah
and that's the infinite bra right there
that's
perfect perfect so
so so in so
in essence the the infinite bra
superhero that we just talked about the
invisible man is
both i love it i love it it's both
no form and all form
yeah exactly it all comes now to them
i think we can end it here i think so
too it all
comes down to the interplay between form
and emptiness
exactly emptiness if you realize this
like the experiential and cellular level
moment to moment there's nothing more
like everything comes down to
emptiness and it's the it's and it's
lila of form and emptiness
that's it does come down to the heart
sutra but also it's lila
the the play component of it it's like
like orobindo says it's the childlike
laughter of the infinite
the child-like laughter of the infinite
the lila
the leela component to the range of
emptiness to all form and
all the no form to all form yeah so
that's it does come down to that and
that's that's the one end and that's why
it's like all the way back to the heart
sutra
but all the way up to infinite bra is
all that same
recognition one end yeah
you know you know the suture after the
horoscope basically the har surprised
the theravada stuff right the the
the passionate path so after that we
have the bhajana and the adriana
they're they're their main sutra i don't
know what it's called i forgot what it's
called
is it the diamond sutra i'm not sure but
it's super psyched alex it's like when
you read it
you can be put into a psychedelic trench
like the way they describe like the
buddha being like
lying with like 10 000 infinite faces
and like each like
each each like atom contains the entire
universe like there's all these
different beans and
you you know what i'm talking about
though
art yeah
the reason why that came after the
nevada is because
that's the the antithesis or the
response or form
to emptiness yes
yes so not just individually as
individuals we go through these
different
uh cycles of form of emptiness and in
the combination of the two
even as a hall as a civilization as a
religious
tradition in itself goes through these
different phases you have the hinduism
of the brahman and then you have the
emptiness of buddhism try to refute that
and then synthesizing both you have the
bhajiyana and the zolchan
and the mahayana which is don't stand on
either side of the nihilism of emptiness
or nothingness don't stay on the side of
eternalism and the absolutism of
almond find the middleweight that can
sense and include both
yep that's it exactly exactly
and and today we have the technology
to animate and simulate and
create at the most experiential
pedagogical level especially for kids
and adults
these visualizations of all no form to
all form
and that is going to be what unlocks
the the diamond around each neck
yeah yeah so let let's let's jump on
we'll jump on our call and unpack that
um
visualization more i want to thank thank
for thank you
frank this was perfect wait is your real
name right
so my my birth name was actually arkhazi
alan sakyan which is armenian and
yeah yeah and then and then and then i
and my my middle name's alan so i did
went by that for a while and then as i
sort of shed
this i the identity it transitioned to
atlas
and then just one name atlas and then
even the last like three plus months
have basically been like
even that's gone now there's no
form or name attached to the identity
there's
that the identity is no form to all form
not even
a layer called atlas so um but yeah
so so that and then frank yang was that
your
als what was your birth name and you're
in taiwan right now
are your parents both uh taiwanese
where where yeah so walk us through that
quick also
um my dad is in taiwan um my mom is in
the u.s and right now i'm sitting on
because i can't really i
i can't really go back to us right now
because of the dynamic and taiwan is one
of the safest places in the world right
now so i'm just totally chilling here
yeah and so your lineage your lineage is
both mom
and dad are taiwanese yeah they're both
taiwanese
okay okay cool and then and then um
was frank yang the american what was
what what's the taiwanese
like birth name also what was uh
the talon's birth name is yang yang shi
yi
yang shi that's my original og
taiwanese chinese name
on the passport for my american passport
is frankie
i like what you say about not even
having atlas bro i feel the exact same
way
it's like the way this thing on before
this frankie and then you're like oh
there's a character here that's not
[ __ ] care but even the character is
dissolving
right now it doesn't feel like i used to
be like oh this character wants to do
this but there's no haircut
yeah so so that's another thing that um
we'll discuss is that
the geopolitical relationship between
like the us and china i was
there in 2019 doing partnership
interviews
and i loved my experience in china and i
really am excited about bringing
together peace
india china saudi arabia russia brazil
all these different
kind of powerhouses just working
together to recognize that
you know this infinite bra nature so
imagine frank and atlas at the u.n
[ __ ] talking about
infinite bra and everybody's like micro
dosing magic mushrooms
yeah go ahead you know who's the
opposite of it bro
um donald trump oh yeah yeah sure sure
sure but they're the same really that's
what i think
yeah yeah the same because like when you
when you
when you are 100 ego that means you have
no ego
yeah that's so interesting yeah yeah but
if you're only 99
you're still going yeah yeah yeah
you you're um you're that you know we'll
keep
we'll keep hitting yeah we'll keep we'll
keep hitting this this ball back
think frank thank you and
the biggest eagle maniac he's such a big
ego to maniac
his ego is a sense of infinity that has
no signs yeah
yep yeah we'll we'll keep okay yeah
let's um so
just quick i just want to end i want to
end the the episode by saying everybody
um i highly recommend checking out both
frank's the youtube channel the link is
in the bio below
he has really exceptional content on
there go and watch that and also follow
him on instagram he has great stories
and great content he posts there
including all these visualizations of
infinitude as well as sort of
step-by-step
understandings of how to recognize like
we talked about
um the the juxtaposition between the
clouds in the sky and then plucking out
even the last thorn of awareness itself
the no form
to all form type oh he he unpacks that
great so go and go and follow and check
him out let us know how you think
about the conversation below leave us a
comment we would love to hear from you
um leave us a comment like the video if
it brought you value subscribe or follow
across all platforms
share the content with other people so
more people can see
sort of an unpack what we're talking
about with awakening enlightenment
and whatnot and that's it that's all
folks we love you very much thank you
so much for tuning in thank you frank
this is so great
i've been doing a lot of packages
recently but this one is uh i don't know
this one is
something else then yeah and that's what
that's what i'm going to talk to you
about right now after this is doing this
type of stuff a little bit more
frequently we'll explore that here in a
bit
much love thanks everybody talk to you
thank you
thank you everyone all the infinite bras
all the infinite brows
bye bye